it's been a while since we've discussed
some Greek mythology and even longer
since we discussed one of the primordial
deities today's video will be on Erebus
the primordial God of Darkness who many
consider along with his wife NYX to have
been the first to primordial beings to
have come from chaos the exact order of
these beings does change depending on
your source but if we go with Hesiod
then we know that he was definitely part
of the first five primordial beings that
Kaos gave birth to quite often people
confuse Arabists and Nix because night
and darkness are things that go hand in
hand but Erebus symbolized the darkness
and all things inside of it whereas Nix
symbolized the night with that being
sent the task of spread in this darkness
across the sky did falter Nix we can
almost look at Erebus as this dark mist
that Nix would unleash and must paint
the sky with when it was nighttime their
children Humaira and aether would then
sweep the starkness away bringing with
them a new day from chaos came forth
Erebus and black night but of night two
were born aether and de whom she
conceived and bore from union in love of
Erebus Hesiod doesn't really mention
urbis in any story or in any great
detail but that is the description he
gives in his Theogony together Erebus
and Nix fathered and mothered many
deities and some of these included
Hypnose Styx nemesis Thanatos and the
Mariah along with her mara and aether
who we mentioned earlier before the
likes of Hyperion Helios Apollo and any
other deity associated of the Sun the
ancient Greeks or Erebus and aether as
the sources of day and light and that is
how they explain the cycle as opposed to
the Sun Erebus and Tartarus were also to
day teas that were closely linked as
some Sauron day came Erebus retreated to
the darkest recesses of Tartarus because
of this Erebus can must be considered as
the first god of the underworld and it's
this association of Tartarus that led to
Erebus becoming a tome that referred to
a place in between the earth and the
under
their souls would have to travel through
I know this video has been rather short
but when compared to the Olympians we
just really don't know much about the
primordial generation Erebus himself is
probably the least discussed of the
initial five but that's not to say that
he wasn't important
the ancient Greeks used eros as a way to
explain the darkness and in turn its
relationship of light why so many places
may have been darker than others
Erebus and Tartarus also gave us the
first concept of the Greek underworld
that poets and storytellers were then
heavily expand upon feel free to share
your thoughts and ideas and Erebus with
me in the comments below as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained